oh dearest mother i write you so full of
joy i might burst our unit secured yet
another victory that makes five straight
or an entire hand as some say the
dolphin men put up a great fight but our
aquatic drilling paid dividends
our trusted sniper capped the wind i am
beaming
andrew
it sounds like captain andrew celebrated
a little captain morgan how about you
see
gets a little loose after wins
that's the captain andrew luck tweet
following the cult's victory
over the dolphins and the interpretation
from
chris sims we're still not quite sure
what you're going for there it continues
to sound like british vampire although
this english gentleman is a drunken
drunken british vampire would be there's
no i'm just going to stop right there
all right colts defeat the dolphins
27-24 the dolphins are up 24-14 in the
fourth quarter but if you let andrew
luck hang around exactly he's going to
get you how did he get him well i you
know i think just his ability to stand
in the pocket them have pass protection
the way they do you know and yesterday
we saw finally you know a few cracks in
the scene finally with that offensive
line where they let up some sacks uh on
the miami dolphins dolphins of course
have some good pass rushers coming off
the edge but
andrew luck and his ability to make
throws down the field especially in big
moments it's as good as anybody we've
seen in football through his career i
mean he's a special deep ball thrower
and they're never out of a game there in
indianapolis and i think that coupled
with some conservative play calling by
the miami dolphins in some big
situations there at the end it just kept
giving them some hope and if you give
andrew luck and the colts hope he's
going to burn you at some point and
that's what he did the season was almost
derailed though for the colts in the
first half how about the play when
jacoby brissette throws the pass to
andrew luck
stretches him out and then he gets
slammed onto the shoulder the throwing
shoulder that knocked him out for a year
what in the world is that now i know
what percept was doing we laughed about
that in the viewing room yeah brucette
knows this is his chance throw it high
yeah hospital
but uh yeah that was just weird and luck
said after the game he's done playing
receiver so uh now andrew luck and they
had the
the ebron special as they call it last
week they threw the pass to him and it
was over his head he said he's done no
more no more running past routes he's
going to stick to playing quarterback
and here are the colts with five
straight wins amazing to see what's
happened there were some games early in
the year that i think they should have
won so they
you know if they just come up a game or
two short of the playoffs they are
really going to be seen yeah they're
going to be sick about that texas those
games in september right yeah well that
was the game where frank wright decided
to go for it on fourth down and yeah
right and gave the ball back to the
texans and let them win the game instead
of just taking the tie that tie could
have been the difference
between getting into the playoffs or not
depending upon how it plays out but
those games in september and october you
know they don't speak much about what
kind of a team you're going to be in
december but those wins all count toward
the final analysis and and there's going
to be plenty of teams that are looking
at those standings and looking back at
their schedule and saying oh god we it's
this game that did us in it's that came
that did yeah they have that moment the
jets game right where they they played
horrible got off to a bad start let the
jets offense make a lot of big plays on
them throughout the day but they have
righted the ship and then there's two
things that i think you know or maybe
three things that jump out about the
colts first off their defense it's it's
not like overwhelmingly good but they
don't make a lot of mistakes they make
you earn it they're gonna make you
execute they're very sound they're in
the right spot always and then their
offense having balance because of this
offensive line it gives them a chance
they can run the ball for the first time
in andrew luck's career they can pass
protect and he can sit back there and go
man i could take an extra hit you know
hitch step back here and pat the ball
and wait for ty hilton to come open i
can see he's going to come open and now
i'm going to be able to throw it where
years past he might have had to scramble
or get the ball out of his hand that's
where they are dangerous and we got to
give frank reich again credit i think
we're seeing another week of evidence
where we go wow the colts had some
special game plan design plays against
the miami dolphins and we sat there and
watched the philadelphia eagles and said
man their offense is stagnant and
there's not a lot of great ideas i think
frank reich is proving that you know
he's pretty creative at drawing some
some plays up on a weekly basis a couple
of tough tests coming up well it would
have been tough before the season began
at jacksonville although look maybe
jaguars can be dangerous hey that game
was came down to the wire last week yeah
but i just feel like the jaguars i feel
like they've folded the tents yeah you
know i after after getting to the afc
championship game last year and going
one and eight over their last nine i
just i feel like they're just they're
let's get healthy let's stay healthy
through the end of the season let's get
out of here and get on to the off season
at the texans after that though that's a
huge game then they host the cowboys
they've got the giants and then they go
to tennessee to end the season so the
colts still very much alive five wins in
a row and captain andrew luck very very
pleased very happy with where this team
is and you know you start thinking about
who the teams are that we're going to be
focused on for next year the colts are
going to be one of those teams that are
darling of the media and we're going to
be saying hey they're destined to win
the division next year because they're
going to be i remember chris ballard
told us at the league meetings that you
know everybody wants a win now we want
to win now we want to win now but he he
finally said as a practical matter we're
two drafts away yes right so you give
them another draft you give me and
they're going to be drafting a lot lower
than all the money they're going to have
to spend them for you oh they've got
more than anybody else exactly so you
look at it and the way on bell yeah
well i mean whatever it is but they can
get another weapon on the offensive side
of the ball the offensive line most
importantly is set up that's the big
thing chris ballard has done he has
settled that unit down now andrew luck
who's their big investment is protected
and their defense they have a lot of
young talent across the board i got to
give chris ballard a lot of credit for
what he's done and of course frank
wright for coaching the team and just
because they they're going to have more
salary cap space than anyone i still
think chris ballard will resist the
temptation to overspend on the first few
days of free agency because dollar for
dollar you can get some great bargains
right look they got eric ebron sure for
peanuts two years 13 million dollars now
there was a reason why he was available
for that amount because he had
underachieved in detroit but look what
they turned him into yeah he's got 11
touchdowns in 11 games this season and
and
frank reich told me last week that
they're always sitting around thinking
about ways they can use eric ebron that
they're just so fascinated by what a
talent he is and i remember coming
coming out of north carolina right he
was drafted power than odell beckham jr
yeah this is a guy that that there was a
lot of faith in there was a lot of hope
but there dropped passes in detroit and
he just didn't fit there it just didn't
work for him there it's working for him
in indianapolis and if they can make
some good decisions like that next year
yeah add some impact value designing
yeah value signings impact players guys
that for whatever reason it didn't work
in their marcus hunt who didn't work in
cincinnati he's there dominating on the
d-line for them i'm with you they've got
they they get get used to the years of
the colts being good again because i
think they're here hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports